oh [ __ ]
pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
it's the Joey Diaz show coming over the
airwaves [ __ ]
greetings [ __ ] I've had the
morning from hell I've taken 18 shits
I've had two complications my cat got
sick over [ __ ] that night woke me up
in the middle of matter how am i
somebody was stabbing it I had to take
it to the vet I got stuck it's been a
morning from [ __ ] hell I finally
calmed down I got a [ __ ] sandwich of
me a protein shake and now I'm ready to
go greetings [ __ ] just because I
had a rough morning that don't mean I
came home I retained my God and now I'm
back like a [ __ ]
we got bread tonight ain't got time for
[ __ ] bad days some people have a bad
morning in their whole day freaks out oh
my god who gives a [ __ ] you take a deep
breath you say I'm lucky to be alive and
you get back to the [ __ ] car you go
home and you smoke some reason you start
all over again that's it my cat's fine
then put a [ __ ] laxative in her
[ __ ] we'll know if it's a [ __ ]
hairball in about an hour and that's it
the rest is [ __ ] history there's
nothing you could do you just move on
you can't cry and now I need to meet you
and have a drink them [ __ ]
homogeneous them but Joey what's with
the chitty-chat let's get this
[ __ ] party started
never eat seafood salad from raus jesus
[ __ ] christ
jesus [ __ ] christ jesus [ __ ]
christ
you try to touch trust people you try to
give up on carbs you try to eat on the
run you try to eat handsome you
understand me nobody gonna do you
maintain you do [ __ ] and you move forward
anyway you guys Joey Diaz is throwing a
boast and get your party started
Thursdays Sunday Tuesday I don't give a
[ __ ] you understand does that tell it
all about
[Music]
I got one more radio station I got a
meeting there to pick my wife up I got
[ __ ] to do today then I got to drive all
the way to [ __ ] bread but I don't give
a [ __ ] I ain't complaining you know what
there's my life that's the most
important thing we've got time to be who
gives a [ __ ] Trump Cruz I gotta suck
your dick at the end of the day you
still gotta go to work
you still gotta put it together you
still gotta go get weed you still have
to go pick the kid up from school what
the [ __ ] Saint
this is the only bottle that then it's
real it's awesome we have no commitment
to one another just love the reefer
that's it I don't want none from you you
know one none for me would you smoke and
razor who's better than us they can't do
this in queue but they can't do this in
[ __ ] Egypt we're doing this right
here and a [ __ ] channel called
periscope who's better than you so yeah
rather [ __ ] up morning I feel bad for
my cat behind the leg move forward
oh yeah go against roof we let me Papa
Helene boozled me Paco le bouche or
without it so [ __ ] that means like
Stalin said you never move back you move
[ __ ] forward like a savage everything
but you don't give a [ __ ] at the end of
the day either they suck it dick are
they suck you dick
anyway but well Joey's here we had a
nice week on the podcast wall - stole
last night but that happens in trains
every once in a while you fall over the
top I went to flappers and now I'm in
Brad this week either you come and they
end up I understand you got plans just a
family reunion you want to play the
drums and you squat on your foot
what bones the [ __ ] spirits there
speedy tours ma do you think it's easy
doing this [ __ ] all [ __ ] dang it I'm
still coming down off the 700 milligrams
last night you know why cuz I'm an
American why cry who's gonna listen why
you gonna cry for who gives a [ __ ] smoke
your weasel make your notes
take your mugs you have a tuna fish
sandwich and get back just don't eat the
[ __ ] seafood seller rauch understand
remember black people love Red Lobster
finish it that's it I got [ __ ] to do and
people to see and I suggest you do the
same you understand me I don't want you
sitting out here all day I'm smoking
join my uncle Joey yeah I don't know use
a little a excuse don't [ __ ] throw me
into your [ __ ] prongs [ __ ] I
call you smoke the bomb that I dropped
you off that's it
don't say then go back to work and uncle
Joey gave you a star at that later that
[ __ ] I love you guys with all my life
you know they have a great time with you
guys without you guys otherwise I got
[ __ ] dick
we got weed we got one another there's
no blow nobody's eaten pills nobody's
going to rehab nobody's standing one
another just like a Grateful Dead
concert up periscope
he's better than us you look at how you
want kids don't do this at home kids
again warning I'll do this at home I
don't want y'all calling me your dad I'm
smoking dope with Joey the [ __ ] to an
apartment who says things like this
it's my little poker combination poke
the stabber [ __ ] barbecue falafel
type thing we call those things you get
the skewers with the [ __ ] meat kebab
I love those things
especially in New York when they give me
the [ __ ] bounty me it took his heart
for 12 hours an aphrodisiac those Arabs
don't [ __ ] around the west side of
Manhattan
we think should we smoke another bone or
is it time to go 'no i have to go to na
my life is falling apart I haven't
spoken to me forward junkie Joey on
periscope I can't take it double your
[ __ ] yourself well go off for [ __ ] 3
beep well I judge Washington crossing
the Hudson River boop boop beep boop
boop boop beep boop
just little one your son looks I just
like a social you ever get together with
your friends you'll smoke the number
just like a bank and associate by our
mantra ego so see I don't have big
Natalia before like a month or Kennedy
compound boy it is in
well that's that
I have lost control of the plane Google
anyway I love you [ __ ] to see you
and Brad to hell it's redstone night and
Braille it's myself Johnny Rock
my main man Tommy Easter with the 4/20
[ __ ] review on a daily Tommy's
but don't give a [ __ ] about mud you
don't respect communist you don't like
Chinese people dummies but all [ __ ]
around and that's it you know
we don't need to wear my look like a
sculpt cat happen have a cigarette in my
mouth I could seem cool ivana dirty
[ __ ] I'm a felon I don't give a
[ __ ] about nut I'm here you're here what
together all right stay black
have a good day if you can't see my head
balls not cuz I have sunglasses on
[ __ ] for a reason
you got me stoned what you did to me
today
all right I gotta go stay black I have a
good day which always lows you watch
your back
you guys open there's some mysterious
[ __ ] big